was haben sie gestern abend erlebt wir
haben das erlebt die schweizer
gastronomie und wir haben das liga spiel
gehabt gegen eine andere gastronomie aus
im weiteren vor ort und habe dann gegen
22.10 schüsse gehört wo ich dann mehr
gedanken gemacht haben dann raus
gekommen
hab dann hat man nacht bei der von der
pizza her gesehen der dann zu mir
geschehen hat völlig deckung jenes werde
geschossen schießerei und
dann habe ich dann weitere schüsse
gehört bin dann um die ecke von den
eingang von mir im laden gegangen und
haben die leute gesagt die sollen von
den fenstern fern bleiben dass jemand
die in die gastronomie schießt bin dann
auch wieder raus um die ecke richtung
diese shisha bar gelaufen habe dann auf
der linken seite gesehen dass jemand
daran gelegen hat und habe dann in
klamotten guckt da hat einer gelegen
und wenn dann auch für ängstliche zurück
glaubt versucht die polizei anzurufen
das war ja dann auch besetzt gewesen
habe ich erst mal einen streifenwagen
gesehen der dann an getroffen ist den
schockierten polizisten der dann in
jemanden gesehen hat der gegenüber
gestanden hat da wo die hausnummer 5 ist
und wer da gelegen hat und hat auch
verstärkungen gerufen
ich bin dann erst mal um die ecke
gegangen und habe mir gedacht dass der
täter noch hier in der gegend ist und
nachdem die ersten polizeiwagen hier
eingetroffen habe ich mich wohler
gefühlt und aber hab dann wiederum
wieder schüsse gehört aber das war dann
bisschen in der ferne wo ich mir dann
gedacht habe okay das ist
nicht normal ist ich ging als erstes
über einen bandenkrieg aus eventuell
weil man das so letzter zeit viele so
was hört aber dann haben schon
mitbekommen durch den freundeskreis das
das da freund von mir verstorben ist der
in diesem chaos aber diese arena bar
gearbeitet hat dann sein verstorbenes
den ich auch kannte sehr vernünftiger
junge der da weiß er wahrscheinlich von
seinem onkel gewesen war und dann hört
man dann über die über die gruppierung
über ebay whatsapp gruppen über im
freundeskreis dass da mehrere gekommen
sind sagen so ihre freunde was sagen die
prämien sind die entsetzte kann man sich
so etwas bei uns gut meine meine familie
die schockierten sagen halt ja lasst den
laden ja und andere freunde
gehen dann immer letzter zeit so wie
diese wegen der politik ja geht stark
davon aus dass da halt die
rechtsextremisten die wie afd
die sich da immer stärker werden und
klar kann ich die deutsche seite
verstehen ja ich bin hier groß geworden
auf kooperationen ich machte jahre
ich kenne nur deutschland und die türkei
kenne ich eigentlich nur aus dem urlaub
wieder an drauf der deutschstämmige ist
dann halt dann heißt ja klar man muss
nichts erwarten ja wenn man als
deutscher in seinem eigenen land schon
dass wir ihnen fremd fühlt sagen manche
ja ich sehe das hat ein bisschen
schwachsinn aber klar wenn man dann auch
aus dann politisch ja wenn da hat die
politik sachen sagen wie also
rechtsextremistische fiel im vorstand
kommt die prozentual in der wahlen da
gewinnen da kommt wieder so dass rechte
wieder wieder zum vorschein
da kriegt man schon ein bisschen angst
dann darüber dass vermehrt haben sie
gestern gesehen hatten die täter sehen
können den täter daten der soll er soll
das habe ich jetzt auch von meinem gast
verfahren der auf der anderen
straßenseite das sehen konnte der kommt
auch später ins geschäft der mir gesagt
hat dass er einen schwarzen pulli anhat
kapuze und
der dann in die richtung zudem einen
jungen daran im haus nummer 5 gelegen
hat geschossen hat und dann in richtung
die tip-in gelaufen ist die lediglich
sicher war sie ungefähr abschätzen
diesen schlüssel haben sie waren die
ungefähr hier war dies das wahlrecht
laut gewesen das war recht laut gewesen
ungefähr sechs bis sieben schüsse habe
ich gehört und acht schluss so glaube
ich das war dann das ging ja bam bam und
danach erst mal nix und sein widerpart
schützen gewesen
ja das war wie an fasching einen car
loslässt jahre so mehr bitten sie sich
vorstellen dass so was in sie sind ja
haben sie kleine tiere ja gut ich bin
haben aber ja ich kenne ich bin hier
groß geworden ist ja klar hat man hier
freunde man hört dann über eine gehört
man aber immer nur schlägereien oder
oder halt messerstechereien
das ist aber schon die messerstecherei
nicht schone eine sonne schon für uns
beängstigende sache und aber so messen
schießerei nie wenn man hat so über
anderen freund gehört hat dass einer
irgendwie die dohle hat da hat auch
schon die polizei schnell gehandelt oder
die staatsanwaltschaft ruhe ist dann hat
seine gespräche in den jahren die ich
jetzt